I can't believe this I live here now
yeah going up in the world I'm proud of
you sister look at this creature you
wanna keep a secret what's this it's my
book JT Leroy how is this game so JT's
like your pen name more like my avatar
the book is doing really well
people need to hate him now when I first
saw you I thought you look like him huh
you've got all these cells inside of you
it's or them
a Hollywood producer wants to make Sarah
into a movie so good to finally meet you
JT did you get that book I sent you why
do you keep answering for him he's a
deaf mute you establish yourself as
someone else JT you're here blast and
nobody even notices you sound like a
woman to me but you insist you are a man
are you really who you say you are are
you really who you say you are I can't
really tell them are you a man you're as
much a part of JT as me I just wanted to
tell you how much your work means to me
it's super real for some people you know
fun want you she wants some rights to
the movie under every time you come back
from being JT running a piece about
Savannah they look strikingly like mr.
Leroy I'm not gonna do it anymore this
is because of my writing you're not
really quitting her team you are so if
you would have
[Music]
understand
nobody gives you anything you have to
take it
please tell me you are who you say you
are
[Music]
understand
you